bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde en direct
ce soir
Eric Coquerel réélu finalement sans
difficulté aucune à la tête de la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être notre
grand témoin ce soir un grand témoin un
peu spectateur du ce spectacle désolant
vous nous le direz ou pas des divisions
à gauche combien de temps la nuit pèse
peut-elle encore tenir on en parlera
longuement tous les deux tout à l'heure
notre grand débat ce soir comment
protéger l'information et l'indépendance
des rédactions le grand chantier des
États généraux premier par Emmanuel
Macron s'est ouvert aujourd'hui
concentration des médias rachat brutaux
secret des sources la liberté de la
presse semble en péril dans notre pays
les députés veulent même légiférer nous
en débattons dans un instant avec nos
invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir
Yanis roder et ses histoires d'école le
regard sur le monde du grand reporter
Vincent Hugo et puis des punaises de lit
très politique ce sera dans le bourbon
Express d'Elsa mondain GABA voilà pour
le menu on y va les récré
[Musique]
impossible de ne pas penser à la
centaine de journalistes grévistes du
JDD qui ont dû quitter à contrecoeur
leur journal à la fin de l'été c'est en
partie seulement pour répondre à la main
mise brutale de Vincent Bolloré sur le
Journal du Dimanche et ses conséquences
sociales et éditoriales que sont donc
lancés les états généraux de la presse
et de l'information que peut-on attendre
très concrètement dans un moment où la
liberté de la presse semble fragilisée
dans notre pays bonsoir Christophe
Deloire merci beaucoup d'être là puisque
c'est vous qui allez piloter pendant 9
mois ces états généraux de l'information
vous en êtes le secrétaire général et
vous êtes exalte également secrétaire
général de Reporters sans frontières on
a pas mal de questions à vous soumettre
ce soir bonsoir violette spielbou
bonsoir merci d'être sur ce plateau
député renaissance du Nord porte-parole
du groupe majoritaire à l'Assemblée
nationale bonsoir Sophie Tellier polian
bienvenue vous êtes député génération
apparentée écologiste du Val-de-Marne et
vous avez déposé une proposition de loi
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir à vous retourner
Eric Coquerel pour accueillir Stéphane
blackovski alors ces états généraux
alors au départ les états généraux de
l'information c'est une promesse du
candidat Macron en 2022 et comme elle
est ressortie du tiroir au mois de
juillet c'était pile à l'époque où la
rédaction du GDD s'était mis en grève
pour protester contre la prise de
contrôle de Vincent Bolloré et donc on a
eu le sentiment que ces états généraux
de l'information était une réaction un
petit peu à l'actualité faut dire que
dans notre pays on le sait il y a une
dizaine de milliardaires qui a un seul
possède une grande partie des médias
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on a annoncé ces états
généraux bien les députés se sont
mobilisés avec une proposition de loi
pardon transpartisane dont vous venez de
parler on reconnaît certaines de nos
invités qui étaient présentes à la
proposition loi a noté que les LR et le
RN non pas participé donc l'idée c'est
de proposition de loi c'est que un
propriétaire veut nommer un directeur
dans une dans son journal dans la
rédaction et bien les journalistes ont
un droit de vote pour accepter ou
refuser des directeurs et s'il
propriétaire ne veut pas se plier à
cette méthode et bien il ne touchera pas
les aides de la presse versées par
l'État ça c'est la proposition de loi
mais en fait avec ces étages généraux
Emmanuel Macron en tout cas quand il en
parlait en 2022 il avait une autre idée
en tête que simplement la l'indépendance
des journalistes sa priorité c'était
surtout de lutter contre les ingérences
étrangères dans le domaine de
l'information d'ailleurs il a souvent
mis les pieds dans le plat à ce sujet
voyez ça c'est une déclaration 2019 où
il mettait en garde contre les
ingérences russes on sait que ça a été
le cas d'élection américaine élection
Royaume-Uni élection en France là aussi
désigner la Turquie où il s'inquiétait
de l'ingérence au moment des élections
présidentielles mais on peut donner un
exemple plus récent de l'actualité
regardez on s'est inquiété toute la
semaine dernière des ingérences russes
en Slovaquie sur les réseaux sociaux qui
favorisaient les lég négative donc la
liste de prorus et bah de fait on a bien
fait de s'inquiéter puisque c'est le
candidat prorus qui a été élu donc vous
voyez lorsqu'on veut défendre une
information et c'est le but de des États
généraux libres indépendantes et fiable
on doit pas seulement se méfier des
milliardaires français qui veulent
museler journalistes il faut aussi se
méfier des États autoritaires qui
veulent déstabiliser les démocraties
explications David colon qui est un
chercheur à Sciences pour l'écoute un
certain nombre d'États autoritaires ont
entrepris depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années de mener un conflit contre les
démocraties qui a pour objectif de les
affaiblir de les subvertir en recourant
notamment à la manipulation de
l'information à l'instrumentalisation
des théories du complot avec le recours
à toutes les techniques possibles
médiatique alors attention parce que là
des informations russes c'est pas de la
propagande à l'ancienne on chercherait à
vous convaincre que Poutine est sympa ou
que la Russie c'est super mais à la fois
plus subtil et plus dangereux les
explications de Raphaël Luxman qui
s'occupe de ce sujet au Parlement
européen et qui témoignait devant le
Sénat
c'est ingérence elle vise au chaos par
exemple c'est pas faire la pub de la
Russie sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
soutenir les pôles les plus extrêmes du
débat public dans nos pays dans le but
de rendre notre débat public chaotique
alors sans vouloir être trop pessimiste
si l'objectif des États autoritaires et
d'empêcher tout dépasse sereins dans les
démocraties en tendant favoriser les
engueulades entre les extrêmes qui font
monter l'audience mais qui n'aboutissent
rien ils sont pas loin d'être arrivé à
leur but parce que regardez les sondages
nous disent que 9 Français sur 10 et ce
qui aujourd'hui que on ne peut plus
débattre sans que ça tourne
immédiatement à l'affrontement et au
dialogue de sourd est-ce qu'on peut
corriger ça ça sera une des questions
il y en a d'autres qui pourraient semer
des désaccords entre vous mais attention
pas de dialogue de sourd merci beaucoup
Stéphane Christophe Deloire c'est vrai
quand on regarde le périmètre de ces
états généraux de l'information c'est de
ouh là là c'est très très large il l'a
dit Stéphane la question de la
désinformation des ingérences de
puissance étrangère à cette question du
secret des sources la question de la
concentration des des médias rien que ça
et j'en passe c'est beaucoup est-ce que
c'est pas trop pour être efficace
des médias protection de secrets des
sources etc
on est dans un moment du fait de
l'évolution technologique de
bouleversement de notre espace public de
cette place du village on échange les
idées les opinions les informations et
qui au fil de l'histoire avait fait
l'objet de garantie démocratique qui
était des principes à travers la
régulation quelle qu'en soit l'effort à
travers l'autorégulation la l'éthique
journalistique par exemple à travers un
développement culturel qui peut être la
culture au sein des rédactions qui
permettait d'apporter quand même des
garanties sur la fiabilité de
l'information ça n'était pas un système
parfait mais c'est un système qui a été
détruit tout a changé et par ailleurs on
se retrouve dans un moment
mondialisation de l'information
c'est-à-dire cette place du village
avant elle était quand même socialement
nationale et maintenant elle est ouverte
et donc toute cette construction
historique elle a été balayée il faut
reconstruire alors on peut reconstruire
en trouvant des solutions à chacun des
problèmes et c'est très loi de le faire
c'est très positif et il y a tout un
travail qui était entreprise il y a
beaucoup de propositions sur la table et
d'ailleurs les États généraux
repartiront du travail parlementaire qui
a été fait mais pour ne pas seulement le
faire par petit bout si je peux me
permettre cette expression c'est
important d'avoir une vue globale et ça
c'est un des premiers atouts je crois
des États généraux et le second grand
atout c'est d'en discuter avec les
citoyens alors expliquez-nous ça c'est
un grand forum 9 mois vous allez mettre
tous les acteurs qui précisément et
quelle place pour le citoyen
en fait il y aura trois modes de
participation il y aura une
participation d'abord citoyenne
professionnelle et du monde de la
recherche s'agissant de la participation
citoyenne on va travailler sur les
règles du jeu au fond de la place du
village
et on peut pas le faire sans les
citoyens ça sera absurde on va pas le
faire en entre soi dans une logique
corporatiste c'est un sujet démocratique
fondamentalement démocratique et donc
nous avons lancé dès ce matin une
consultation citoyenne qui est en ligne
sur le site des États-Unis de
l'information chacun peut participer on
va lancer un tour de France on ira voir
les Français là où ils sont organisant
des assemblées citoyennes sous chapiteau
il y a beaucoup de médias d'organisation
de fédération qui vont organiser des
événements c'est un chantier collectif
qui va être long on va prendre le temps
mais pour arriver à la fin à une
stratégie et un plan d'action pour la
France sur ces sujets alors stratégie
plan d'action puis je fais tourner la
parole donc j'ai compris les citoyens il
y aura aussi pour les ne pas les nommer
Patrick drahe Vincent Bolloré les
propriétaires les actionnaires vous
allez les entendre le législateur aussi
et les journalistes ça c'est une
évidence tout le monde contribué
[Musique]
pour faire quoi pour arriver à des
propositions concrètes des propositions
qui seront remises au chef de l'État qui
décidera ce qu'il en fait c'est ça
l'idée
le comité de pilotage on est cinq à
piloter dans ce comité de pilotage avec
le président Bruno Lasserre mais on
remettra aussi parlementaire avec qui on
discute aux Français ça nécessite une
appropriation générale une appropriation
générale alors on va parler de votre
texte parce que c'est à la fois
complémentaire puis ça pourrait même
aller plus vite que ces états généraux
vous allez nous le dire Sophie Tellier
pollium mais déjà sur la démarche vous
vous aviez soutenu les grévistes
d'ailleurs tous les élus ici du JDD vous
regardez comment cette ce grand forum
vous dites enfin bienvenue ou attention
usine à gaz potentiel moi je suis
contente que ça commence ça faisait des
mois que le gouvernement le président de
la République depuis qu'on a été élu on
en parlait mais il va y avoir les Etats
généraux de l'information etc bon bah ça
arrive tant mieux peut-être regretté que
ça arrive quand même assez tard et
peut-être aussi en raison de cette
nouvelle crise dans un dans un journal
le JDD qui sur une crise grave mais qui
n'est pas une crise nouvelle c'est à
dire qu'il y a déjà eu des épisodes mais
pour vous c'est le problème principal en
fait on a parlé de beaucoup de thèmes la
concentration des médias et peut-être
même au-delà de ça la main mise brutale
d'un d'un patron de presse enfin d'un
industriel sur un journal il y a
plusieurs problèmes mais il faut
effectivement moi je suis tout à fait en
accord traiter les choses de manière
globale mais de mon point de vue je
pense qu'il y a au moins trois quatre
questions auxquelles il faut que les
États généraux répondent et faux
derrière que ça se concrétise et
notamment je pense par une grande loi
parce que parce que il y a il y a des
éléments dans la loi aujourd'hui qui
sont obsolètes donc un c'est la question
de la concentration des médias avec
notamment comment on mesure cette
concentration et comment on empêche
qu'elle soit si importante qu'elle
entrave le débat et la pluralité dans le
débat public ça c'est absolument
essentiel mais deux il y a aussi la
question du service public de
l'audiovisuel qui a été fragilisée il y
a un an par la décision d'Emmanuel
Macron de supprimer la redevance faut
quand même qu'on réponde à cette
question quels moyens pour un service
public de dieuvisuel qui garantissent
lui aussi donc
et puis il y a aussi bien entendu en
fait parce que je pense que c'est
indéniablement lié la question du statut
des journalistes de leurs conditions de
travail de comment on garantit
l'indépendance aussi parce que parce que
les salariés ils ont des conditions qui
leur permettent de de résister aux
pressions ça c'est
encore ce périmètre mais en réalité il y
a aussi évidemment la question
technologique et d'autres et d'autres
questions moi je pense qu'effectivement
il faut il faut traiter tout ça de
manière globale mais il faut pas non
plus et c'est peut-être aussi une alerte
se perdre il faut arriver à des
décisions qui seront soumises
et on a démontré qu'en tout cas sur un
certain nombre de sujets avec la
proposition peut pas trans partisane que
j'ai développé que j'ai déposé avec mes
collègues on peut avancer
il y a tellement de sujets mais juste
médias par jour à le jeu pas de méfiance
des États généraux dit comme ça moi j'ai
aucune raison de douter de la sincérité
de l'enthousiasme de la motivation de
Christophe de Loire bien évidemment
en revanche comment ne pas être inquiet
face à un pouvoir qui a déclaré on a une
presse qui ne cherche plus la vérité en
pleine affaire Benalla comment ne pas
être inquiet d'un gouvernement qui a
voulu faire voter un article 24 dans la
loi sécurité globale les journalistes ne
pouvaient plus filmer les forces de
l'ordre comment ne pas s'inquiéter d'un
schéma du maintien de l'ordre qui
prévoyait qu'on sacrédite pour les
manifestations en tant que journaliste
comment s'inquiéter ne pas s'inquiéter
d'un gouvernement qui supprime la
redevance vous l'avez dit comment ne pas
s'inquiéter d'un pouvoir qui dépose
plainte régulièrement contre les
journalistes parce qu'ici atteinte au
secret de la défense nationale parce que
là fuite de documents
le ministère du Travail donc oui la
liste est longue bah vous répondez là
dessus puis ensuite on parlera de la
proposition de loi Emmanuel Macron
a-t-il un problème avec avec
l'indépendance de la presse moi je crois
qu'Emmanuel Macron en lançant les Etats
généraux de l'information des montres
qui veut une démarche ouverte
indépendante ça a été long effectivement
pour choisir les experts qui feraient
partie de ce comité de pilotage
justement pour garantir ce travail qui
soit vraiment à côté du politique et pas
pour le politique donc ce que vient de
présenter Christophe de Loire ce matin
avec ses assemblées citoyennes ce
travail aussi avec les chercheurs les
universitaires moi je pense que c'est
très important ce que l'on voit sur ces
états généraux de l'information c'est
que ça va être un catalyseur des
initiatives nous à la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
depuis un an qu'on a été élu on a déjà
commencé le travail qu'on va verser dans
ces états généraux je pense à la mission
que j'ai menée sur l'éducation critique
aux médias et le sujet de la lutte
contre les fake news et de l'information
des informations et puis aussi à la
mission actuelle d'évaluation de la loi
Bloch qui est une loi sur les conditions
d'exercices du métier de journaliste qui
est en cours avec là aussi des collègues
en mode transpartisan nous ce qu'on veut
c'est que ces états généraux prennent
l'ensemble des problématiques y compris
celles que vous évoquez le sujet de
l'intervention des politiques que ce
soit d'ailleurs sur le les médias privés
ou les médias publics l'intervention des
politiques l'intervention des chefs
d'entreprise ce lien entre le pouvoir et
la liberté de la presse et ce qu'on veut
aussi c'est qu'il traite le sujet de la
déontologie et de la transformation du
métier le métier aujourd'hui d'un
journaliste qui a sa carte de presse il
se confronte à des influenceurs à des
blogueurs à plein de nouvelles formes
d'informations sont-elles valables non
valables ça fait beaucoup de sujets
est-ce que ça relève de la loi je ne
sais pas pas tous les moments vous avez
raison
que sur du législatif mais aussi alors
je vous propose une collectivité on se
concentre sur deux grands sujet mais ce
qui se trouve qu'au Parlement européen
on est en train de légiférer en ce
moment c'est hasard du calendrier sur la
question donne notamment du secret des
sources dans une deuxième partie mais on
va commencer sur la concentration des
des grands médias privés d'abord dans
les mains vous le savez de quelques
milliardaires on va revoir cette
infographie qu'il s'appelle Vincent
Bolloré Bernard Arnaud Patrick Drahi
Daniel crétine ski Martin Bouygues et
j'en passe ils sont une grande poignée
une dizaine de grands industriels à
détenir la quasi-totalité de la presse
alors tous ne font pas pression sur la
ligne éditoriale et le choix des sujets
traités mais rien aujourd'hui ne les en
empêche faut-il une loi pour garantir
l'indépendance de l'information et des
rédactions et bien il y a certaines
d'entre elles de rédaction comme le
monde où les échos qui ont déjà des
règles très strictes explications Hélène
Bonduelle et Mediapart également
regardez
ce devait être une formalité François
Vidal devait succéder à Nicolas Barré à
la direction de la rédaction des échos
mais ce jeudi 28 septembre la rédaction
du journal en a décidé autrement
candidature rejetée massivement par 67%
des journalistes le candidat proposé par
le Conseil de Surveillance du journal
n'a pas convaincu la crainte que la
rédaction perd de son indépendance face
à l'actionnaire majoritaire le groupe
LVMH a été plus forte c'est notamment la
corde indépendance signée en 2007 lors
de l'arrivée de Bernard Arnault qui
permet aux journalistes des échos de se
prononcer sur le candidat proposé par
l'actionnaire la croix libération ou
encore le monde ont également le pouvoir
de valider ou infirmer la désignation
d'un directeur ça évite justement les
à-coups provoqués par des actionnaires
qui voudraient donner une coloration
politique par exemple à leur journaux et
qui choisirait forcément des affidés là
on considère que la rédaction d'une
certaine façon elle
sait ce que sont les règles
journalistiques elle sait qu'elle est la
mémoire du média dans lequel elle est et
elle respecte ça et donc le dirait elle
choisit son directeur en fonction de ses
valeurs journalistiques ça a toujours
été notre cas d'ailleurs au monde avec
un tel accord l'arrivée de Geoffroy
Lejeune venue de Valeurs Actuelles
aurait sans doute été rejeté par la
rédaction du JDD alors faut-il une règle
commune à tous les médias si on estime
que les journalistes
que les médias
participent dans notre pays il faut
aussi qu'on soit des entreprises qu'on
est entreprises exemplaires en termes
démocratique donc il faut absolument que
il y ait une démocratie vivante en
entreprise qu'on est notre mot à dire
autrement dit un droit de veto des
journalistes qui pourraient être
garanties par la loi
alors Éric Coquerel est-ce que vous
seriez prêt là on a trois députés ça
fait largement une majorité si on prend
vos groupes respectifs dans l'hémicycle
à voter une proposition de loi dans ce
sens pas de d'aide à la presse si cette
droite de veto sur la nomination du
directeur de la rédaction n'est pas
respecté oui bien sûr on peut même voter
une loi qui oblige au fait que qui fasse
en sorte que le droit de veto sont soit
efficients même sans la question des
droits
on peut très bien décider d'une loi qui
donne le pouvoir ce pouvoir aux
journalistes moi je pense cette loi là
si elle était votée pour bien comprendre
ça empêcherait Bolloré
avec le JDD précision on est dans une
situation catastrophique mais
catastrophique pour les libertés et la
démocratie si on considère quand même
que les médias tiennent une place de
plus en plus importante dans nos
sociétés
que parfois c'est même le seul lien
social avec l'extérieur
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens et je
rajouterais à côté de ça la question des
réseaux sociaux qui est qu'on doit pas à
mon avis séparer de la domination du
monde de l'argent et on se retrouve dans
la situation totalement inversée de ce
que craignait le Conseil National de la
Résistance en 46 parce que on a ce
moment-là décidé des choses sur la
presse pas de concentration aux mains de
d'une personne de plusieurs titres de
médias le fait aussi que des groupes
économiques
extérieures justement de médias ne
pouvait pas posséder des médias
obsolète donc moi je crois que bien
évidemment ça passe notamment par le
fait de redonner plus de pouvoir aux
journalistes et de d'éviter comme ça des
situations absolument incroyables ou
quelqu'un est rejeté par l'ensemble de
quasiment d'une rédaction et son patron
le financier peut l'imposer mais ça
passe aussi par le fait de remettre en
question cette concentration pourquoi
parce que bon finalement l'histoire de
Bolloré est un bon révélateur parce que
tant qu'elle est pas eu Bolloré bon le
fait que des milliardaires possédaient
plusieurs médias et donner quand même
bon on dira ce qu'on voudra quand même
immédiatement
le monde de la finance d'ailleurs des
gens qui ont un intérêt notamment à la
perpétuité au fait que le système se
perpétue tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et
bien possède ce qui va permettre
d'orienter le pignon des gens de manière
massive et donc ça ça ne va pas la
dépendance de la presse à mon avis passe
par le fait de sa naissance
de l'extrême droite ça se révèle encore
plus l'autre sur votre proposition doit
transpartisane c'est-à-dire c'est une
loi qui à la fois interdit la
concentration en tout cas la régul très
fortement pour qu'il y ait pas que
quelques personnes qui possèdent toute
la presse ou 90% de la presse et puis
deuxièmement et bien c'est aussi de
donner des garanties dans l'exercice de
leur métier aux journalistes qui un
collectif dans une rédaction et qui est
le modèle de ce qui a été négocié là qui
a été du monde et pourquoi c'est
important c'est parce que la liberté de
la presse c'est consubstantiel elle a
pas de la démocratie il y a pas de
démocratie s'il y a pas une information
libre et pluraliste donc en réalité ces
entreprises il faut qu'elles aient des
règles particulières on peut pas être
compatissuader je pose la question de
d'investir la presse est en crise est-ce
que c'est cette proposition de loi
existe si on renforce les concentrations
non parce que il faut quand même des
financiers
en fait de la presse mais il y a quand
même aujourd'hui dans notre pays des
médias qui qui cherchent qui trouvent
des des formes de modèles économiques il
est prémunissent d'actionnaires qui
seraient comment dire gentiment
indélicat ou carrément interventionniste
et au service de leurs intérêts en
vérité qu'elle soit dissuadée d'investir
ou pas c'est pas tant la question ce
sont quand même des milliardaires sont
par économique aussi ils sont très
largement subventionnés par l'État au
travers des aides directs 110 millions
d'euros en 2022 les industriels qu'on a
cite et que ce soit Patrick Drahi
Bernard Arnault Dassault et j'en oublie
un il va me revenir Niel sont les quatre
principaux
bénéficiaires de ces aides 14 millions
d'euros pour le groupe de Bernard
Arnault un des hommes les plus riches du
monde qui possèdent un groupe de un
groupe parfaitement profitable est-ce
qu'il y a pas philosophiquement quelque
chose de problématique dire que l'état
donne de l'argent à des groupes
industriels qui sont profitables
bénéficiaires pour financer ces deux
lois qui sont des leviers d'influence
dont on ne connaît pas ni les
actionnaires directs indirects on
pourrait rendre public tout ça qui sont
les actionnaires directs indirects des
médias par exemple les packs
d'actionnaires qui sont qui sont scellés
entre les actionnaires d'un média il
faut savoir d'où on parle en fait quand
on est un média vous seriez favorable à
pousser cette proposition en fait de
partir de ça déjà
elle apporte elle est concrète
elle est assez largement soutenue il y a
d'autres modalités possibles la loi
Bloch c'est une loi quand même qui a été
adoptée en 2016 visait notamment avec
des dispositions différentes pour le
duel pour la presse écrite a renforcé
l'indépendance éditoriale et l'éthique
on voit qu'elle a pas suffi
national il y a une commission
d'évaluation une mission d'évaluation ça
nous permettra d'en savoir plus il y a
des propositions formulées par d'autres
organisations aussi moi il me semble que
je suis pas en train de prêcher pour ma
paroisse mais que les États généraux
peuvent être l'occasion de discuter dès
lors qu'on se met d'accord effectivement
sur le fait que l'indépendance
éditoriale c'est un enjeu majeur on est
dans une situation aujourd'hui de
spécificités françaises pas tant sur la
concentration horizontale c'est-à-dire
sur la taille des groupes au fond les
groupes de médias français sont plus
petits que certains groupes allemands
norvégiens enfin de beaucoup de pays
d'Europe mais notre spécificité en
France c'est les concentrations
verticales c'est l'intégration dans des
groupes qui ont des intérêts économiques
ailleurs et ça quand on interroge les
Français et pas ça fait pas un pli c'est
la première le premier facteur de
défiance et donc au fond qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ça finalement il y a deux grandes
options la première option c'est de se
dire est-ce qu'il y a moyen de
développer des modèles économiques qui
permettent que des groupes puissent se
développer et pas simplement quelques
groupes il y a des exemples mais il y a
part est un exemple le groupe qui s'est
développé et qui arrive à vivre et se
développer recruter malheureusement il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'exemples et donc
est-ce qu'on arrive à trouver un modèle
économique de des modèles économiques de
substitution
comment gérer des formes de transition
et puis l'autre moyen c'est la situation
égale comment on sécurise l'indépendance
éditoriale et là ça vaut la peine
l'anglais
que c'est un sujet comme sur beaucoup de
sujets relatifs aux médias où il y a des
formes de polarisation et notamment
cette question du droit d'agrément du
droit de veto il y a une polarisation
très grande il y a comment on arrive à
le dépasser et peut-être en reposant la
question de manière plus générale moi je
crois qu'on peut arriver à faire bouger
des lignes
les journalistes grévistes qui ont
quitté le JDD ils vous dis si au moins
lourd de grève historique avait servi à
ça une proposition de loi le combat
serait déjà gagné donc là vous vous
allez le faire quand quand vraiment en
tout cas ça juin vous faites ça au
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale qui
décidera du moment où on va le
majoritaire pour renaissance
des États généraux justement de la
question de des aides publiques du
modèle économique est-ce qu'on ne doit
pas aller plus loin est-ce qu'on doit
parler aussi on a parlé de la nomination
du directeur de publication on pourrait
parler
une globalité ça c'est des discussions
ça commence maintenant qu'on va avoir
ensemble je crois que vous allez
auditionner les parlementaires dès le
début des États généraux moi ce que je
vois cette proposition mal s'il y avait
un texte de loi avant la fin d'État
généraux
c'est un problème moi j'ai pas discuté
de la journée
annoncé ce matin qu'on allait
auditionner les parlementaires
compétents sur ces questions je suis
compétent ceux qui ont travaillé sur ces
questions et intéressés et des
différents groupes
pour ne pas repartir de zéro parce que
ce sera absurde et honnêtement on va pas
en 9 mois refaire même avec en ayant des
dégâts de travail on va pas refaire la
Commission à souligne du Sénat tel
Commission on n'a pas capacité mais pour
essayer de d'arriver à d'autres
propositions qui qui synthétisent
dire sur cette proposition de loi que
c'est que derrière le sujet du de la
conditionnalité des aides publiques qui
peut paraître insuffisant comme méthode
on va dire pour pour faire évoluer cette
indépendance et ce rôle des journalistes
il y a le sujet est-ce que le média est
un bien culturel français c'est le JDD
quelque part c'est des années d'histoire
avec une ligne éditoriale avec quelque
chose qu'il faut respecter et est-ce que
lorsqu'on est actionnaire on peut
brutalement changer une idée tutoriale
laisser partir parce qu'il vous faites
parfois interdire Vincent Bolloré
la concentration il y a le risque de
l'arrêt du pluralisme si tout était
concentré dans un seul dans une seule
main et pas seulement des médias mais
derrière de toute une chaîne culturelle
parce qu'on sait que c'est même
milliardaire il possède aussi des
théâtres du spectacle du livre et ça
pose la question aujourd'hui de la
préservation du pluralisme des idées des
opinions en France c'est ça qu'on
préserve ensemble à travers une première
proposition de loi qui peut-être sera
transformée en plus ambitieuse plus
complète à la fin des États-Unis
mais en réalité cette proposition de loi
que je vais redéposer sous forme
d'amendement budgétaire elle pourrait
tout à fait être mise en oeuvre sans que
pour autant le débat ne puisse pas avoir
lieu sur est-ce qu'il faut continuer les
aides à la presse ou pas est-ce qu'il
faut mettre d'autres dispositifs ou pas
mais là ça garantirait aux journalistes
maintenant dès aujourd'hui
d'avoir je dirais une un levier de plus
à leur disposition pour en cas
d'ingérence des actionnaires GA agir le
respect de l'or déontologie alors
l'autre sujet
qui vient percuter un peu le contexte
dans lequel ces états généraux sont
lancés c'est la protection des sources
là on parle plus des des grands groupes
privés avec avec des industriels à leur
tête mais là on parle de l'État depuis
2017 il y a une dizaine de journalistes
qui ont subi une garde à vue pour nous
respecter de secret défense et la
dernière date c'est notre conserve du
site disclose Ariane lavrieux qui a été
perquisitionné interrogée pendant 39
heures à l'enquêtait sur une opération
antiterroriste de l'armée française
détournée au profit du pouvoir égyptien
est-ce que la France
doit-elle balayer devant sa porte en
cette matière de protection clairement
secret des sources est-ce que on doit en
tant que journaliste recopier des
communiqués de presse la réponse est non
est-ce qu'on doit révéler des
informations d'intérêt public la réponse
est oui on a un média freelomates qui en
discussion en ce moment au Parlement
européen je crois que la France a plutôt
poussé pour limiter cette de protection
du secret des sources en permettant dans
des cas où je crois que l'expression
c'est la sécurité nationale est en jeu
l'introduction de logiciels espions dans
les téléphones des journalistes
franchement est-ce que ça c'est digne
d'une grande démocratie je sais pas je
Christophe de Loire je me pose la
question ce sujet-là
je veux dire de du texte de l'uepn
médias freedomac et des réactions qui je
pense de la part de personnes qui n'ont
pas vraiment lu le texte ce texte
journaliste qui ont
un texte qui vise à répondre à deux
sujets et qui a été proposé par cette
Commission européenne qui disons-le et
de toutes les commissions de l'histoire
de la Commission européenne qui a fait
le plus sur la question de la liberté de
la presse et des médias
avec deux objets la montée de
l'autoritarisme Pologne Hongrie et
la capture de média par des intérêts
économiques ces deux objets c'est un
texte qui permet de pousser des droits
et qui va surtout les sujets plus loin
que que la législation française sans
être un texte parfait mais il est un
texte très positif il y a une question
française alors j'ignore pas la question
de la position française sur une
expositions
et le texte a été adopté par le
Parlement ça m'entraîneur il y a une
position du Conseil de l'Union
européenne avec
une position du Conseil de l'Union
européenne qui a notamment été affiché
par une position française qui vise à
poser une exception générale sur les
questions de sécurité nationale mais il
est faux de dire que c'est un texte
liberticide disant que ça fait régresser
et que ça à espionner les journalistes
il y a un champ d'exception entre large
mais par rapport à un progrès c'est pas
du tout la même chose je pense quand
même qu'il faut la tu ramener un peu de
raison
moi je suis en accord avec ce que vous
venez de dire c'est-à-dire que
globalement on est sur un texte qui
prône des avancées au niveau européen
mais juste je reviens à ce que disait
tout à l'heure comment effectivement moi
je suis très très attentive à ce qui va
se passer dans les états généraux de
l'information pourquoi parce que là on
vient d'avoir un exemple concret sur la
protection des sources on a voté une
résolution ici même à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce texte européen et on a
adopté un amendement tous ensemble dans
l'hémicycle 10 ans il ne faut pas que la
protection des sources soit remise en
cause au nom du secret d'état on l'a
adopté ici que fait le gouvernement
français en Europe il s'assoit sur une
décision souveraine du Parlement prise
sur à l'appui de plusieurs bancs sur
l'initiative d'une de mes collègues donc
je vais dire un moment donné c'est vrai
que les interrogations sur que va faire
le pouvoir dans ces états généraux de
l'information on peut que se les poser
donc
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup d'espoir
dans votre action parce que vous portez
une vision qui est quand même très forte
et une action très forte mais c'est vrai
aussi que aujourd'hui et là dans les
jours qui viennent qui viennent de se
dérouler on voit un gouvernement
français qui n'est qui n'est pas du tout
à la hauteur qui controvient des
décisions de l'Assemblée nationale et
qui effectivement met en danger la
protection des sources dans notre pays
mais est-ce que vous pouvez rassurer ce
qui nous regardent parce que il y a cet
amendement qui a été voté il y a la Loi
datty sur la protection des sources qui
pour certains est trop vague puisque il
y a une exception voilà qui dit que
quand il y a un impératif prépondérant
d'intérêt public ça justifie de
contrevenir à ce secret ce qui est ce
qui laisse un peu la porte ouverte à
toutes les interprétations est-ce qu'il
faut des garanties des garde-fous très
clair aujourd'hui au plus haut niveau
sur ce sujet moi je pense que dans
résultats généraux il faut si on veut
aboutir à quelque chose d'opérationnel
de concret c'est à dire une loi
transpartisane qui soit votée largement
et qui protège les droits des
journalistes le pluralisme
l'indépendance il faut qu'on s'autorise
à revoir les critères de la loi de 2010
qui sont peut-être trop larges sur
l'exception de sécurité nationale
l'exception de prépondérante d'intérêt
public pour être exact en tout cas on
est quand même dans un monde qui a
évolué ou la menace les guerres les
conflits et la guerre de l'information
les ingérences vous montriez des
exemples tout à l'heure sont réels donc
remettre en perspective avec ceux qui
nous attend une loi qui date de 2010 moi
ça me choque quand même pas simplement
il faut qu'on s'autorise à discuter de
tout ça que on s'autorise à avoir une
proposition de loi ou un projet de loi à
la fin des États généraux qui soient
très larges et qui prennent aussi ce
sujet fondamentale
la raison d’état le secret des sources
alors vous aurez le mot de la fin
Valentine oui non vraiment je trouve
quand la matinée en la matière Reporters
sans frontières à d'excellentes
propositions propose de supprimer
l'impératif prépondérant d'intérêt
public qui est beaucoup trop vague pour
le remplacer par une disposition plus
restreinte et proposer que la violation
abusive du secret des sources soit
sanctionnées par un délit spécifique
excellente proposition de reporters
on reviendra on aura un droit de suite
pour voir comment vous vous travaillez
merci à vous merci d'être venu débattre
sur LCP vous restez avec moi Éric
Coquerel dans une petite dizaine de
minutes les parties prises de nos
affranchis ce soir rien il se redèrent
qui va dénoncer l'enfer des mutations
pour les profs vincent Hugeux qui nous
dresse le portrait on en parlait du
nouveau président pro russe en Slovaquie
et puis ça va gratter ce soir dans
Bourbon Express Elsa oui puisque je vous
parle des punaises de ligne il y en a
partout il y en a même dans le débat
politique merci à vous à tout à l'heure
mais d'abord comment va la gauche
Eric Coquerel vous personnellement vous
êtes plutôt en forme vous avez été réélu
à la tête de la très puissante
commission des finances à l'Assemblée
mais le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que rien n'est réglé au sein des
fractures profondes qui divisent la
nuque on voit ça avec Marco pommier on
en parle juste après
si on vous invite Éric Coquerel c'est
parce que vous rempilez à la tête de la
stratégie commission des finances de
l'Assemblée merci beaucoup un temps
sursis après avoir jugé recevable la
proposition loi du groupe pour approcher
la réforme des retraites vous vous êtes
finalement bel et bien imposé comme
président de la commission
je dois dire que depuis le début de ce
mandat il a montré un grand respect des
oppositions un député insoumis à la tête
de la commission des finances du jamais
vu pour un trots engagé à la Ligue
révolutionnaire pendant 15 ans vous
l'adolescent anarchiste dont la rue des
14 ans vieux compagnon de route de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fidèle parmi les
fidèles et pourtant écartés de la
direction de la France insoumise
qu'importe vous ne vous éloignez pas du
rivage insoumis alors que vous aimez
prendre le large Éric Coquerel
navigateur amateur passionné de voile
organisateur du premier Vendée Globe en
page 68 a dans lequel on rêvait soit de
transformer le monde soit pour certains
si on y arrive pas d'en faire le tour
aujourd'hui
Eric Coquerel vous naviguez en eaux
trouble le navire amiral nupes semble au
bord d'une naufrage personnellement je
ne fais pas la nupaisse parce que j'aime
les autres je ne les aime pas alors pour
le bien de la coalition faut-il se
débarrasser du passager au sel ou du
capitaine Mélenchon et dans un tel
climat les élections européennes ne
sont-elles pas l'iceberg du Titanic
nupes pour l'instant c'est chacun son
cap chacun sa liste vous souhaitez
pourtant l'Union chez les insoumis ce
soir notre question va de soi Eric
Coquerel comment maintenir la coalition
à flot
réponse avec coquerelles
oui oui j'y crois oui j'y crois pour une
bonne raison je vais vous dire c'est que
moi je considère qu'on a une politique
toujours plus réactionnaire à la tête de
l'État je n'hésite même pas à dire que
sur certains aspects il y a une extrême
droiteisation
du gouvernement sur bien des aspects
autoritaristes violences policières la
façon de discriminer
etcives autoritaires je trouve quand
vous avez un ministre de l'Intérieur qui
en plein été donne raison à des
policiers qui réclament le fait que
contre la justice de ne pas pouvoir être
mis en
détention provisoire alors que la
justice a décidé je pense que c'est des
choses qui m'inquiètent donc je vous dis
je connais
la question et que ce soit avec le RN ou
que ce soit avec une droite qui s'est
extrême droitise je crains pas morte
donc je vous explique à partir du moment
il y a un danger comme ça le pays en
général
et bien il faut le rassemblement de
toute la gauche sur un programme de
rupture qui consiste bien mais pour
l'info et pour l'instant peut-être mais
ce que je vous fais remarquer c'est que
la dernière élection principale les
présidentielles législatives ont donné
une majorité justement à cette gauche
qui prend la première fois est une
gauche depuis longtemps en tout cas est
une couche qui s'incarne sur un problème
de rupture qui est le seul à même de
battre l'extrême libéralisme et
l'extrême droite
à la présidentielle oui je pense pas aux
différentes élections intermédiaires on
le voit c'est chacun dans son coin aux
européennes c'est probablement la même
chose pour les municipales le mode de
scrutin attendez
le pire n'est jamais certain que en tout
cas sur les européennes c'est fini a
priori c'est fini vous abandonnez mais
il reste quelques mois et moi je pense
qu'il faut continuer à dire que une
liste
rassembler de la nupes serait largement
préférable pour nous mettre en rapport
de force justement par rapport au pire
qui peut nous arriverons
vous vous dites ça j'en sais rien et de
cette manière en tout cas je suis pour
essayer de conserver un espoir à la
nouesse à partir du moment et j'insiste
là-dessus parce que l'unité c'est pas
juste Lyon la gauche la dupeye c'est
j'allais dire une pointe avancée de
l'Union Populaire que nous voulons qui
est sur un programme de rupture et je
pense que par exemple ce que nous
faisons vous m'interrogez à l'Assemblée
je regarde moi j'essaie de regarder ce
qui marche non mais il y a l'Assemblée
et donc là où la lupesse c'est créé
c'est à dire les députés et bien ça
continue à fonctionner on fait en sorte
que ça soit le cas
on voudrait comprendre c'est lui qui
part ou c'est vous qui lui montrer la
porte il y a une forme de rupture là on
est atteint un degré de violence verbale
peut-être mais on a quand même un
problème avec Fabien Roussel alors le
tout c'est ça devienne pas un problème
et que le Parti communiste et de dire à
nos camarades communistes bah il faut un
moment donné que vous nous disiez le
choix parce qu'il a dit que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
c'est que depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois presque dès le lendemain de
l'élection et on sait qu'en réalité dans
les négociations il n'était pas le plus
farouche partisan de la nupes il annonce
la fin de la nouvelle il explique par
exemple que quoi qu'il arrive il se
présentera notamment en 2027 ça a déjà
causé l'échec de pour la nuit pèse
d'arriver au deuxième tour avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il le dit à l'avance à chaque
fois que tu dis moi j'écoute ce que dit
Fabien vous savez à chaque fois qu'on
est attaqué par exemple Darmanin nous
attaque il y a des mots doux pour
Darmanin on nous attaque sur tel ou
telle biais il se débrouille pour donner
raison à case neuve qui sont les plus
antidou pesses au parti donc je dis pas
dehors je dis qu'à un moment donné on
peut pas avoir des mots comme ça qui
sont des mots défiance vis-à-vis de la
new peste et penser que ça n'a pas de
réaction donc nous on pointe le problème
je pense qu'on a bien fait se le poser
et il y a du Dorion
elle a repris un propos d'un de vos
confrères Daniel chederman Nicolas qui a
fait une analyse par rapport de Roussel
je ne suis pas d'accord etc je vais vous
dire pourquoi bon parce que elle est
beaucoup trop
dur par rapport à à Roussel et
deuxièmement en plus ce que ça fait
c'est que ça ressoude le Parti
communiste autour de lui qui se sont
attaqué donc elle est contre-productives
mais je vois pas qu'on inverse la
question parce que c'est pas cette
phrase le problème elle est très
violente hein
c'est pas ça que porte Manu bon pas ce
que porte-t-il panneau ce que nous
portons que par rapport à la nuque ce
n'est pas notre notre expression
officielle l'expression officielle c'est
que nous avons des critiques politiques
sur la politique monnaie par Fabien
Roussel aujourd'hui et je dis une chose
moi je souhaite que les
de manière totale marche très bien que
Nicolas sont tués à la commission des
finances mais pour ça il faut arrêter
j'allais dire de tirer sans arrêt contre
son camp c'est ce que fait
fabiennes qui s'interrogent on va aller
voir hautain Ruffin Garrido Corbière on
sait qu'il se réunissent entre
régulièrement c'est un secret de
polichinelle même avant les groupes la
réunion du groupe des insoumis si même à
l'Assemblée
ils ont raison de s'interroger sur la
candidature Mélenchon comment vous
regardez leurs démarches
là vous vous personnalisez la question
moi par exemple sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je lui dis moi j'ai porté à certains
moments certaines critiques par rapport
à la manière dont on organisait France
insoumise d'accord d'un autre côté je
vous dis aujourd'hui la candidature de
Jean-Luc c'est celle qui devrait
s'imposer celle qui la plus efficace et
c'est celle que je soutiens donc moi je
n'ai pas entendu les camarades dont vous
parlez pointer leurs questions sur la
candidature Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est pas
ça qui est la question moi un peu quand
même quand même non non parce que la
candidature
Jean-Luc cadillum si aujourd'hui si on
verra dans 2027 qu'il en sera et ses
décisions mais si l'élection aujourd'hui
se déroulait très franchement une
quasi-totalité de France insoumise
estimerait que le bon candidat c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et j'en fais parti
alors on fait un peu de la tambouille de
la nupes et des insoumis la commission
des finances que vous présidez va
commencer à examiner le budget 2024
éducation justice intérieure écologique
pouvoir d'achat tous ces budgets sont en
forte hausse le gouvernement ne fait pas
le choix de l'austérité il ne coupe pas
brutalement dans les dépenses est-ce que
c'est un choix que vous approuvez au
moins
alors c'est assez étonnant ce budget
parce que
c'est un budget qui finalement ne résout
rien on va dire c'est à dire que le
gouvernement a un discours d'une
politique libérale qui est de dire il
faut revenir à 2,7% difficile en 2027
c'est ça vraiment l'objectif essentiel
c'est la dette etc
il annonce que progressivement
2025 où il annonce 12 milliards de
dépenses en plus de moins de dépenses en
termes de service public donc voilà
c'est son objectif mais d'un autre côté
ils se retrouvent coincé par certaines
évidences alors par exemple c'est le
pouvoir d'achat le fait que vous avez 9
millions de Français de pauvres c'est le
fait que la transition écologique c'est
quand même difficile de la faire sans
argent
et puis arrive il est obligé de mettre
une bombe sociale comme le logement avec
le fait que les gens n'arrivent plus à
se loger bien ou se loge trop cher et
que on a une crise sans précédent et je
s'arrête les cadeaux fiscaux au plus
riches que l'on a fait depuis des années
on remet
l'isfaits du capital ont bien profité
des années Macron et c'est pas juste un
problème de justice fiscale c'est que ça
nous coûte juste par exemple en 2022 50
milliards d'euros de recettes ça c'est
une chose deuxièmement je continue
par exemple vous savez c'est 75 riches
plus riches français des milliardaires
qui aujourd'hui ont un taux d'imposition
sur le revenu inférieur à 2% et si on
regarde le revenu globaux professionnels
ils sont même pas à 25% d'imposition
quand la moyenne pour les pour les 10%
les plus j'ai 45
il nous reste une toute petite poignée
de secondes impossible d'arrêter cette
interview sans vous poser la question
sur Sophia chez qui roulent la députée
de Paris qui va être convoqué par la
justice en vue une possible mise en
examen selon nos confrères du monde pour
la gestion financière à la légalité
discutable de sa société de
communication mediascope
qui est intervenu dans plusieurs
campagnes de la France insoumise quel
est votre réaction la réaction c'est que
j'entends parler beaucoup de
convocations depuis maintenant des bois
sur ces histoires de 2018 il y a pas que
ce fiatch qui rouille il y a eu d'autres
personnes on nous a dit que il y a
d'autres personnes qui ont été
convoquées dans les différents à
plusieurs reprises par rapport à la
campagne de 2018 dont je rappelle que
les comptes avaient été certifiés et on
nous annonce sans arrêt beaucoup de
choses ces choses n'arrivent pas donc
quand elles arriveront on en discutera à
ce moment-là mais je vais vous dire une
chose moi déjà par rapport des
adversaires politiques j'ai pas je
commente vraiment très très peu non
seulement les décisions de justice avant
qu'elles soient prises mais alors en
plus les annonces de décision de justice
Eric Coquerel vous restez avec moi c'est
l'heure d'être parti pris de nos
affranchis ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite
Yanis roder de la Fondation Jean Jaurès
et une nouvelle histoire d'école et le
grand reporter Vincent hugieux pour son
regard sur le monde qui nous emmène ce
soir en Slovaquie installez-vous les
amis on commence comme chaque soir par
un Bourbon Express qui gratte un peu je
pense elle va dans un Gabin bonsoir oui
je vais vous raconter l'histoire d'une
petite bête qui n'en finit plus de faire
parler d'elle évidemment je vous parle
des punaises de Lyon on en parle au
bureau on en parle au métro bien on en
parlait celle des quêtes colonnes toute
la journée c'est un sujet de
conversation voire même deux psychose et
c'est un fléau qui est devenu politique
les insoumis depuis quelques jours ont
ressorti par exemple le placard à
archives Mathilde panot en tête à
l'accuse le gouvernement d'inaction
voire même de lui avoir rayonné quand
elle a mis le sujet sur la table dès
2017 en 2020 elle posait même une
question au gouvernement sur le sujet
mais cet après-midi trois ans et demi
plus tard elle l'a refait
hébergé des punaises de lit est un
calvaire elles empêchent de dormir elle
mordent douloureusement elles épuisent
elles usent les nerfs à devenir fou
elles font vivre un calvaire au million
de nos concitoyens infestés elle leur
font perdre le sommeil provoque de la
paranoïa et les isoles socialement
madame la Première ministre ces petits
insectes répandent le désespoir dans
notre pays faut-il attendre que Matignon
soit infesté pour qu'enfin vous
réagissiez la présidente des insoumis
avec sa fiole de punaise à la main elle
a bien précisé en punaise morte merci de
nous rassurer voilà dans la foulée bien
de récupération politique par la
première ministre Elisabeth borne
sur ce sujet il ne devrait pas y avoir
de clivage il devrait y avoir une
détermination collective pour agir alors
madame la Présidente panneau pourquoi
une fois de plus restez-vous dans
l'outrans bon voilà on a senti quand
même que la majorité elle a bien compris
qu'il fallait prendre le sujet en main
exactement c'est même un élément de
langage indonés à toutes les portes
paroles du groupe Renaissance ne pas
laisser dire que rien n'a été fait
illustration donc ce matin le groupe des
gamines conférence de presse les
punaises de lit sont une priorité une
proposition de loi sera déposée en
décembre et surtout bien on rappelle
qu'on n'a pas attendu le week-end pour
se saisir du sujet groupe de travail en
2019 proposition de loi en 2020 plan
ministériel en 2022 on sent que la
majorité est quand même sur la défensive
on a l'impression qu'il y a un petit
vent de panique dans la majorité pas sur
les punaises de lit en elle-même mais
sur le risque d'être accusé de ne pas
avoir pris la mesure du problème et ce
que je me trompe là on dégaine la
conférence de presse la proposition de
loi
il y a un principe de lucidité c'est à
dire que on voit dans le contexte
politique assez violent dans lequel on
est notamment ici à l'Assemblée
nationale depuis un an certains groupes
plutôt issus de l'extrême gauche et de
la France insoumise essayer de créer des
polémiques à tout va
pour salir le débat politique pour
discréditer l'action du gouvernement ou
pour discréditer la majorité
présidentielle je vous le disais donc la
majorité travaille sur un texte avec
toutes les bonnes volontés mais les
bonnes volontés de l'arc républicain
c'est à dire sans le RN et sans la
France insoumise la nuit pèse lance une
autre initiative concourt donc
d'initiatives compétition à l'assemblée
que le meilleur gagne et surtout nous
trouve une solution pour se débarrasser
de ses nuisibles il y avait des
questions Mathilde
et comme d'habitude il n'y a pas de
réponse du gouvernement c'est du grand
jeu des QAG elle a notamment proposé un
service public justement pour que ce
soit l'état de prendre en charge
notamment le prénom charges avec des
moyens qui soient pas des moyens
chimiques au lieu de répondre à la
question et bien on détourne en parlant
de récup
et les Français et forcément sont
attentifs à ce qui pourrait les aider en
la matière Vincent on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec Stéphane Da kowski le
nouveau Premier ministre slovaque est un
populiste pro russe il s'appelle Roberto
et ça n'est pas franchement un Européen
encore moins allié de l'Ukraine alors il
a engrangé un succès certes mais pas un
triomphe crédité de 23% des suffrages le
parti se mer de Robert fitso
prétendument social-démocrate en réalité
nationale populiste araflé 42 des 150
sièges du parlement slovaque lui suit
donc forgé une coalition avec le
concours des 27 élus d'une formation
dissidente du même SMER et les dix
députés ultra nationalistes d'un autre
micro parti pas de quoi tempérer les
ardeurs souverainistes et russophiles du
vainqueur un frère en illibéralisme du
hongrois Victor Hormann arrow qui l'eût
cru sur Bruxelles les migrants et le
lobby LGBT alors que c'est tout sur lui
précisément son parcours ses intentions
alors avant tout qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un perdreau de la saison et moi j'ai
encore d'une colombe ce juriste âgé de
59 ans a déjà occupé à deux reprises le
fauteuil de Premier ministre entre 2006
et 2010 puis de 2012 à 2018 en décembre
de cette année-là le tollé que suscite
l'assassinat du journaliste
d'investigation Yann coutchak et de sa
compagne Martina le contrat à la
démission il faut dire que l'ultime
enquête de coup de chaque publié à titre
posthume porté sur les liens entre
l'équipe de Robert fitso gangrenée par
la corruption et la mafia italienne
deuxième certitude notre revenant a
promis de mettre fin au soutien
militaire que Bratislava fournit à
l'Ukraine plus la moindre munition pour
l'armée de Kiev a-t-il martelé au gré de
ses meetings fixo réprouve les sanctions
infligées à Moscou et préconisent
l'ouverture de pour parler de paix au
contour aussi imprécis que suspect plus
révélateur il endosse la légende de
poutinienne sur laquelle la guerre
d'agression déclenchait par le Kremlin
aurait commencé dès 2014 lorsque je cite
des fascistes ukrainiens ont tué des
civils russes que sa campagne électorale
a été empoisonnée par un déluge d'infox
à la sauce moscovite visant notamment en
michalchiemechka le numéro 2 du parti de
centre droit Slovaquie progressiste et
vice-président tient donc du Parlement
européen donc c'est un coup dur pour
Kiev alors militairement à peine une
chypnose membre de lieu comme de l'OTAN
frontalière de l'Ukraine la petite
Slovaquie 5 millions et demi d'habitants
à céder ce que pouvait l'être avion de
combat compris elle apparaissait
d'ailleurs jusqu'à lors on regarde ses
ressources comme l'une des donatrices
les plus généreuses du Vieux Continent
époque révolue alors après le perdreau
et bien nouvelle métaphore
ornithologique pas plus qu'une
hirondelle ne fait le printemps un
corbeau neuâte l'hiver en revanche
politiquement l'inflexion qui s'annonce
ne serait être minimisée d'abord parce
qu'elle survient à leur même que la
rengaine de la lassitude occidentale
serait née par la poutini et saisidiaux
plus ou moins utiles gagnent en vigueur
quand l'orage gronde la force des
démocraties une légitimité adossée aux
verdict des urnes peut devenir ça
faiblesse la plus pernicieuse en la
matière le péril vient moins du Maillon
slovaque pour t’en nicher au cœur de
l'Europe centrale que du parrain
américain bien sûr Washington a une fois
encore conjurer une extrémiste le
spectre du shutown la paralysie
budgétaire mais le plan de soutien qui
est fait quelques plumes argentées un
avant-goût amer du lachage que
précipiter très l'hypothétique comme
bague de Donald Trump à la Maison
Blanche Dieu nous en préserve et comme
il est écrit sur sa majesté de l'art in
gold we trust merci beaucoup Vincent
voilà une un coup dur pour les Européens
aussi cette élection yanison termine
avec vous vous voulez revenir sur un
papier du Parisien qui racontait le
calvaire des mutations pour les
enseignants calvaire aussi ce sujet pour
Gabriel Attal parce qu'il est confronté
au manque d'attractivité de ce métier
d'enseignant racontez-nous oui Myriam
vous vous doutez bien que certaines
académies sont plus demandées par les
profs que d'autres les bords de mer
plutôt que les bars d'immeubles si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi concrètement un
jeune enseignant
titulaire d'un concours à de grandes
chances de se faire muter en
Île-de-France dans les académies
difficiles et déficitaires où il va
devoir rester quelques années avant de
pouvoir rentrer dans sa région ou tout
simplement dans une ville où se loger
serait plus économique il partira quand
après avoir enseigné quelques années
dans des quartiers de relégation sociale
qu'il ne connaissait souvent que par le
biais de la télévision il sera devenu un
excellent professeur formé sur le teint
et un nouveau petit jeune prenant sa
place alors ça c'est quand on arrive
dans le métier mais pour vous par
exemple tiens Yanis si votre conjointe
était nommé qu'est-ce que vous faites je
dois demander une mutation que je note
je n'obtiendrai pas nécessairement et en
cas de refuge je suis obligé soit de
garder mon poste soit de vivre à 500 km
de ma famille soit de me mettre en
disponibilité c'est-à-dire sans salaire
le temps d'obtenir un poste alors même
qu'un manque de prof et cela peut durer
longtemps en réalité vous savez d'autre
part Myriam qu'il y a les académies ou
aujourd'hui on ne recrute plus assez
d'enseignants notamment dans le premier
degré si vous passez le concours de
professeur des écoles dans certaines
académies vous y êtes coincé peut-être
pour 20 ans il y a même un syndicaliste
qui disait dans Le Parisien notre zone
géographique est une prison par
conséquent on a moins de candidats au
concours dans l'académie de Versailles
500 postes n'ont pas été pourvu en 2022
donc n'imaginez pas qu'on va vous
laisser partir si vous voulez suivre
votre conjoint qui est muté soit vous
vous mettez en dispo soit vous
démissionnez sinon adieu la vie de
famille plus de 2000 démissions dans
l'éducation nationale en 2022 alors
celui-ci sur 850 000 profs c'est pas
beaucoup mais ces quatre fois plus qu'en
2010 toutes ne sont pas évidemment liés
à la question des mutations mais je
pourrais aussi vous parler des preuves
qui sont mutés à des dizaines de
kilomètres de chez eux ou sur plusieurs
établissements à la fois pour compléter
leurs services du coup fait nouveau on a
des jeunes diplômés aujourd'hui qui
refusent de prendre leur poste et je
connais même des enseignants qui
préfèrent rester contractuels
c'est-à-dire dans la précarité car ils
peuvent au moins choisir leur
affectation alors Gabriel Attal a
compris l'importance du sujet va voir
les syndicats qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
vous savez c'est un sujet un vrai sujet
et pour Gabriel Attal bien sûr qui a
commencé d'ailleurs à en discuter avec
les syndicats et donc semble avoir pris
conscience que le manque d'attractivité
du métier de profs tient aussi à la
question de la mobilité on travaille
actuellement à un système d'affectation
plus humain et plus individualisée dit
même le ministère la question est donc
loin d'être anodine et le chantier
s'annonce important et mes techniquement
difficile vous le disiez Myriam on
manque aujourd'hui d'enseignants il faut
donc s'attaquer à tout ce qui bloque
l'envie de le devenir il y a du boulot
si j'ose dire merci beaucoup et anis
roder Merci à VOUS Vincent hugieux Elsa
à très vite et merci à vous et
heureusement et aux revenus des
enseignants et ça tombe bien à ce qui
était il y a 40 ans on va rentrer dans
le débat budgétaire ce sera l'occasion
d'y revenir c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
pour l'avoir ou la revoir et à la chaîne
Youtube de LCP très belle soirée à
demain
[Musique]